this is the first aircraft carrier to be
made in india the ins vikrant whose name
is the sanskrit word for powerful or
courageous
after 17 years of construction and tests
the warship joined the navy with great
pomp and ceremony
today india joins the countries that
have built such large aircraft carriers
with indigenous technology from offshore
petrol vehicles submarines to aircraft
carriers the indian navy's power is
increasing at a rapid pace
this will further strengthen our navy in
the future
this is india's second aircraft carrier
to be put to sea in a significant
expansion of its naval presence it's
also its biggest vessel it can carry
1600 crew members and 30 aircraft it
costs more than two and a half billion
dollars most components came from local
vendors it brings huge capability to
india and indian navy it can project
power
dominate an area show presence
provide humanitarian assistance in
disaster relief in the far reaches of
the indian ocean
gives us the ability to monitor all the
sea lions of communications
this deployment comes as china is
rapidly expanding its military presence
in indian waters
this military survey ship recently
docked in sri lanka despite india
expressing concerns the vessel could
track its missiles
china has also commissioned its own
domestically built aircraft carrier
bigger and more powerful than vikrant
experts say india has a long way to go
before it can match china's military
capabilities india looks upon the indian
ocean region as its own backyard
and the chinese are very rapidly moving
into the indian ocean so the carrier
that has now been commissioned today and
will be operational probably by the end
of next year which is 2023.
the
indian navy hopes to counter chinese
aggression in this area
the navy says it wants to start building
another warship this would be bigger
than vikrant and more powerful to
counter china's growing mind pav
nimittal jazeera new delhi